dinnertime is approaching word has
spread about me being at the end and the
place is bustling I'm learning a lot
about why the inn is struggling by
watching Robert and Ari deal with the
new influx of guess anyone with any
rational experience would stagger the
seating of guests but as if they're just
welcoming people to a dinner party at a
private house hello there how are you
Robert Inari see everyone at once yeah
and the corner make pretend you're back
in 1902 it's a meant to be a relaxed
evening for durin and that's the recipe
for disaster for chef Julian and the
waitstaff chef I'm making a change on 21
write it down don't tell me just write
it down it's an order you guys kidding
me with all these orders who said
everybody at once like this we don't
know about Pacey
who's writing the tickets Jimmy no in
table for Table five some of them have
names on them some of them do not
who wrote that chick it's nothing the
table number on there
[Music]
where's table 23 then I need one person
at a time I need less talking in the
kitchen labels 23 I've gotten over the
window eight people asked me for
something with Judy and haven't been
slammed by the owners dreadful seating
re isn't helping the strain atmosphere
with an awkward artless and then like
this this is from 1800 and it was
painted for Opera House because you know
what it is come on everybody has to know
what that is it's a Hannibal going
across the herbs with the white
elephants everybody should know that
[Music]
on the other side of the house Rob is
also busy giving a lecture this is one
of the original signs to the house
there's a lot of history here Teddy
Roosevelt actually was best friends with
the man or a very good friend with the
man who actually built the house max
whatever George get this back to I mean
yes
yeah when I have four seating
Robert has groups of his friends come
and sitting him at once okay so you're
waiting for your starters that yes okay
let me check on those for you Robert yes
the ticket system is bollocks yeah like
hundred and tickets no time on there no
proper dates that coordination who
trains the front of house team who's in
charge at the restaurant who is that I
would be the host and then usually the
host the chef takes over the kitchen
this place is such a mess
clearly Robert has no idea how to run a
hotel drinks cuz they lose that we lost
thirty something drink
Robert we lost 30 drinks at least I
often find drinks not written down or
just a lack of follow-through and it's a
big problem when we're trying to make
money there's no communication between
the bar and a dining room so people get
served drinks but no one remembers the
chart for them we're losing big money no
kidding and they're losing their chucks
and I'm going crazy trying to figure out
a system they have hardly any guests and
don't charge the ones they do have no
wonder this place is in the red
they're supposed to write the drinks
down and then apply them to a table and
a room and then they go into the
computer the ticket system is bogus
and as I feared seating everyone at once
is already causing problems for the
staff and the guests with guests now
suffering and the kitchen falling apart
robbers ill-managed eating come on I
have to step in just to stop there
you have to be [ __ ] kidding me
this goose liver is burnt to a cinder
stop
Julian yes come on buddy I know we're in
the [ __ ] and we're busy foods dying in
the window a foie gras salad I mean
honestly it's like a piece of [ __ ]
beef jerky where's Ari get me Ari
urgently
I mean honestly come on guys hello I
stopped that I just said it no what is
that what is that Barbara that's foie
gras that is not what grass it's not
funny I know that is not funny I mean I
know we're in the [ __ ] but does anyone
have any standards here yes well can I
see them can I see something down on two
cuz right now I just want to get out of
here I can only be as good as I am with
the tools that I have I'm embarrassed
and I know that I can do better I know
the staff can do better
first off no more [ __ ] tickets in the
kitchen give him ten minutes to catch up
okay all right Robert is it possible for
first time put the phone away get jacket
off and [ __ ] dig deep a little bit
yeah please yeah somebody I'm concerned
that food is in the window and it's just
dying on trade send them there should be
set here how am I supposed to do
everything bad even are you with me and
where you no no I'm with you don't
preneur I keep trying to you know you
can talk so Amy's your [ __ ] Sheriff
well when I try to communicate oh yeah
yeah yeah no no no no I can't do it no
he doesn't [ __ ] find your balls and
telling me I found my ball I do I wanted
to walk out we suffered a will carry we
communicate with him talk to him well I
have been trying to show when he
finishes it sending the [ __ ] food is
always a third dish not ready or a
fourth dish what must be water could
move behind but unless you [ __ ] us
how you supposed to [ __ ] know I have
been asking I said where did this chick
go ask him again
where's Atsuko jillian table 23 I told
you one minute ago I need foie gras
where I know I have it right behind me
all right well it's okay Junior
yes that's what you call communication
it's better communication that's what
you call communication Roberts there's a
difference between interrupting and no
communication and when you [ __ ] put
those entrees up there you make sure
they go you've got to start stepping up
and [ __ ] dictating a little bit cuz
this is just madness
I agree Jesus Christ
it was fuck-ups from start to finish and
it was a [ __ ] and Gordon saw that